[Music]
Brenda Song and Macaulay Culkin pack on
the PGA during a rare outing together
that's the couple holding hands while
taking a romantic stroll around their
Los Angeles home the two all smiles
seemingly enjoying a sweet Audi without
their kiddos yeah no complaints the pair
haven't been seen much since secretly
welcoming baby number two around
Christmas time now I'm gonna make some
babies gonna have some pretty babies it
was reported that their one-year-old son
Dakota officially became a big brother
to a second baby boy named Carson it's
gonna be adorable Macauley and Brenda's
baby news comes a little over a year
since they got engaged I don't like to
talk about your personal life yeah the
lovebirds have been pretty private about
the romance from the beginning Nicole
and Brenda First worked together on the
film changeland
yeah
yeah fight how was it working with Mr
McCauley Culkin wonderful we spent seven
weeks in Thailand with our best friends
and made an amazing movie that I'm
excited to share with everyone in 2017
E.T was the first to confirm they were
an item after being spotted at Knott's
Berry Farm together and fast forward to
2023 the two are now a family of four
yeah Amy Brenda's given a small glimpse
of Parenthood on Instagram no pics of
the kids but she shared snaps of their
trips to amusement parks and the zoo as
for Brenda and McCauley's parenting
style well last year the actress told
the cut they're very Hands-On quote we
don't have a nanny but my mom has been
here with us since my son was born I
feel like I've been really fortunate to
sort of been like swept in the right
direction and had great guidance Brenda
also revealed how the couple keeps the
spark alive after having kids she tells
the mag they have a special ritual they
get into bed and chat about their days
and even when she was working he'd wake
up to talk with her Brenda says now we
do it at night after our sun goes down
it calms me it sounds small but I
cherish it it's nice to wind down with
someone you love
[Music]
thank you